foreign
Warner I'm the producer for the long Now
talks at the interval and your host for
this evening
[Applause]
[Music]
psychedelics another mind-altering
substances are among our oldest
continually use Technologies with
evidence of you stretching back at least
five thousand years
today they remain hotly contested and
are wildly popular despite a 50-year War
on Drugs that's done nothing to mitigate
that here to help us look at that past
explain the present and reveal possible
Futures is Ismael Ismael
good evening everyone
how y'all doing
yeah all right love this energy I want
to appreciate the long now Foundation
this is my first time here at the
interval and it was really cool because
I had heard about the long nap
Foundation before but once this was
announced I had like dozens of people
come up and be like oh my God it's so
cool that you're doing this talk and I'm
also really excited because I love doing
talks in person my name is Ali and I'm
currently the director of policy and
advocacy at the multidisciplinary
association for psychedelic studies also
known as Maps I was born in Fresno
California
I was raised by two parents who were
immigrants my mother was born in Cali
Colombia my dad was born in Delhi India
by raised in kanachi they left their
respective countries to escape political
and economic turmoil and then a few
years later some years later 911
happened and that really changed
everything for me as a young Muslim
raised in the Central Valley of
California some of you may have spent
some time there people also call it the
Bible Belt of the West Coast it was
really interesting to immediately be
kind of thrust I like to say politically
socialized without my consent as a
person who was a Muslim kid
multi-racial multi Multicultural and
just like realizing that there was this
larger Arc of history that was happening
around me and I was kind of forced into
that understanding at a really young age
and it kind of made me really depressed
it made it really difficult I was full
of angst uh full of uh kind of
resistance uh to the status quo as it
kind of was imposed on me
until I wasn't I uh discovered
psychedelics
as a teenager and was immediately
welcomed into Rave culture and I like to
say that that angst turned into
curiosity and that was really a huge
shift that was over 15 years ago and
that shift from angst to curiosity is a
big part of what I think keeps me kind
of going even in the midst of a constant
barrage of really depressing and
continually existentially confronting
news that I feel like we're all getting
all the time
that was my late teens I uh when I was
20 years old I ran into my family member
in Colombia visiting I hadn't seen them
for a long time and I was like
know anything about OSD you know you
know acid at their parties because I was
throwing Raves you know as a young
person and kind of undergrounds and that
was when I learned that I had family
members that had been working in the
realm of bridging transpersonal
Psychotherapy and psychedelic Shamanism
for literally decades so I'm here
telling my family member have you heard
of LSD and they're like you have no idea
so I was taken they took me to the
desert you know when I was in my early
20s I spent some time in um
kind of my first contact with the more
spiritual practice I had been seeking
that but didn't really know what it was
I was seeking until I started to make
contact with some of these older
traditions
so a few years later I went to law
school ended up working for the ACLU of
Northern California and eventually for
maps and over the last few years have
kind of moved into a place where I get
to I feel very grateful for I get to be
in conversation as an educator about
psychedelics to the public to
professionals like lawyers and doctors
but also to legislators I spent a lot of
time now speaking with people who are
elected both in the United States and as
well as around the world around like
what psychedelics are how they work and
in many cases as I can go into more
later
um how to talk about them without
sounding crazy and there are a lot of
people who are interested and who are
kind of interested in the closet but
what's happening is that the barrier to
entry to talking about psychedelics is
starting to reduce I think a lot of you
may be familiar but Maps is a nonprofit
that was founded at 01986. I don't know
how what the what the naming convention
is when you add the zero but I thought
I'd be cute and we've been sponsoring
psychedelic assisted therapy trials for
the last 20 25 years and we educate
people to benefit from the careful uses
of psychedelicus psychedelics and
marijuana so we're really in educational
research organization that is really
looking toward kind of I think for a
long time the frame and this is true of
a lot of drug policy the frame was how
do we dismantle the current system and
what I've realized in a lot of what Maps
works on and what I work on with my
colleagues that are here in other places
is the kind of the building of the
alternative infrastructure like what is
it that we go to we can kind of
dismantle the War on Drugs we can end
mass incarceration we can do all those
things and I really believe that we're
slowly slowly slowly but surely moving
toward that but there will need to be
systems that catch people because right
now the only ones we have are the ones
that are broken or fundamentally working
exactly how they're supposed to
depending on your frame
so Maps is the sole owner of the mass
public benefit corporation which is
founded in 2014
and that organization works for drug
development so it's essentially a small
Pharma company that's working toward
therapy education and creating FDA
approved drugs so right now our Flagship
project which I'm sure a lot of people
are familiar with is taking MDMA
through the FDA approval process and I'm
happy to announce that we just we
recently announced we just completed our
second phase three trial which means
we're now in the last leg before
submitting the NDA to the FDA hopefully
this year the maps has seven principles
that we operate on and they think that
they kind of help give a sense of the
conceptual Arc and the type of work that
we're trying to bring to the world
healing for all
prioritizing public benefit
open science open books I love this one
because I'm all about how do we make
things accessible to the public that are
usually esoteric unavailable knowledge
set the setting some of you are familiar
with the concept of set and setting but
we kind of believe in the city of
setting the setting like we're going to
be create we're actually building out
the setting in which uh political change
prohibition will change and so on as we
speak so there's this idea that we
actually have some agency there this
idea of Consciousness without
criminalization I'll talk a little bit
of criminalization and decriminalization
specifically later on and this idea of
being the bridge we have a really kind
of a white umbrella under which we work
and you can imagine and as you've seen
more and more politically and I think
Andrew and I will talk about this a bit
in the Q a the type of people that are
attracted to psychedelics it's not
really just one type of person anymore
there was that concept for a long time
but that's really not true I think it
never was but there's this idea that
there's a particular type of person who
like looks a certain way and maybe
smells a certain way that's into them
but that's really starting to change and
the final one is my favorite which is
seeing past the Paradox which is just a
gen General concept when we approach
these big complex questions that relate
to criminalization in our future and
where we go from here I want to talk a
little bit about the street because a
lot of people when they think about drug
policy reform and when they're thinking
about these Concepts they tend to start
that clock in about 1971 when the
control Substances Act was passed which
is a perfectly valid spot but I want to
zoom way back and just give a few kind
of Milestones before we even get to 1970
just a frame like my understanding and
how I think about psychedelics and the
current kind of current status of where
we're at I think a lot of people know
this psychedelics have been used
psychological plants have fun I haven't
used throughout history there's evidence
going back literally thousands and
thousands of years and I put this list
up healing cultural communitarian
sacramental political and other purposes
because I think the narrative today is
really dominated by this conversation
about medicalization so these are just
some photos of these like super old kind
of examples of psychedelics and art
somewhere so we've got ellucius we've
got San Pedro we've got really examples
and multiple if not every continent over
the course of a few thousand years so
there's a lot of good evidence for that
and I think that's one of the
conversations that's been re-emerging
which is what does it mean to be
bringing these ancient practices that in
many ways never disappeared into the
Paradigm that we live in today so a lot
of people start the history of
psychedelics and drug policy as I
mentioned drug reform excuse me um
criminalization 50 years ago but I
actually bring it back to the 1500s
there's evidence that when colonizers
entered what they call the new world
that they witnessed the practice of
ingestion of psychoactive plants peyote
and mushrooms among others and
immediately saw that as the devonic
practice so I actually think that the
groundwork for what we now know today as
the War on Drugs started 500 years ago
and that was like kind of the beginning
of the kind of homogenization the way
that kind of culture specifically was
kind of fit through a particular lens
and we see that with the cultural and
literal genocide of indigenous people
throughout history that in many ways is
also very tied to the genocide of
culture itself of like the actual
communitarian practices that we're used
to maintain cohesion that you you know
you can bring that up back up to the
1800s or so you've got a few hundred
years there where practice went highly
underground and it was really like the
mid-1800s or yeah mid-1800s 1880s or so
that you see the beginning of what we
kind of see of the current Global Drug
control scheme in the late 1800s a lot
of the world's superpowers were making a
lot of money off of selling drugs they
were selling all kinds of drugs they're
selling tea and they were selling coffee
but they're also selling opium and a lot
of other things over the course of many
years so when the U.S yes that's us
started pressuring some of these
governments the Dutch government the UK
government and so on in the late 1800s
to start criminalizing substances they
actually there was actually a lot of
resistance from about 1800s to really
after World War II there was quite a bit
of resistance from the globe a lot of
people didn't know this of the desire to
criminalize in the first place because
they're like why would we criminalize
something if we're making Bank off of it
and that started to change as the kind
of global superpower shifted and over
the course of World War One and World
War II and suddenly the U.S which had
banned opium in the 1800s because of all
the Chinese immigrants that are coming
into the west coast to build the
railroads where suddenly was suddenly
not so much of an outlier but was
realizing that these mechanisms could be
used for social control and you see that
repeated in the 1930s with cannabis
so you've got like by the time you get
to you know the mid 1900s you've
actually got quite a few examples of
that criminalization beginning to occur
and it was around that shift that you
see the beginning of the current Western
Medical Research on some of these
substances including LSD MDMA mescaline
peyote Etc and some of it was to treat
mental health conditions you have some
early research on alcoholism Stan Groff
is really well known for his early
research in the 50s in the Czech
Republic with LSD on both survivors of
the Holocaust as well as Nazis there
were some really interesting literature
about research that was then in the 50s
in the wake of World War II with OSD but
a lot of that kind of information
started to really like bubble up in the
mid in the mid 1900s and a lot of us
know a lot of those famous names and
books and so on I'm not going to go
super into that today so by 1951 there's
over 100 articles and a lot of people
maybe aren't super aware that a lot of
research was happening really fast
people were really excited about acid
you know they really were they really
were it was like nothing else they had
seen before you know like or you know
people thought that at least so there
was a lot out of there was just a lot of
like potential in a lot of and there's a
whole Shadow history that I'm sure a lot
of people know about that I'm not going
to go into today around using the CIA do
some mind control I'm not going to talk
about that today that's really its own
conversation but it's worth getting into
if you don't already know
so bringing us back up to the 1960s so
that criminalization that had started
with various tax acts and various other
kinds of restrictions begins to be
encoded into law and actually I think
California criminalized LSD a little bit
before the control Substances Act was
passed so you kind of start to see a
little bit of that groundwork being sent
early on and it was really 1971 that
this was encoded into law and then all
this started to happen scientific
inquiry quashed tens of millions this is
like funny but it's really not it's
actually horrible and it's what's been
happening for the last 50 years millions
of people are incarcerated hundreds of
thousands of people are killed and I
wanted to pause here because I mentioned
earlier my mom's family is from Colombia
the reason that they left in 1986 was
because the violence in Kali was so bad
that people would tattoo or wear their
blood type on them because there were so
many people who had to get sent to the
hospital and I want to say that because
it's really important it is important to
talk about incarceration and so on but I
really like to remind people that the
War on Drugs is a global effort and the
U.S really LED it and there's really
good literature about how the US
pressured the rest of the world in the
U.N and so on to do that but I just want
to mention that like the cost of our
cheap access to Great drugs here in
California like really does have a
violent tale like a lot of these drugs
that are manufactured in other parts of
the world actually have an impact on
people and that has caused a lot of
Challenge and literal violence in many
places over the course of history and
currently
and of course it's really expensive we
spend a ton of money on enforcing stuff
some people may be know this already but
the plan Colombia you know the
eradication of Coca the pesticide use in
Colombia those laws a lot of those early
laws in Colombia were written in English
by U.S lawyers when we just when we
handed them to the Colombian government
we were like this is what you're going
to do and we funded it we spent billions
and billion spend current present tense
billions and billions of dollars on
eradicating a plant that by the way
grows a lot everywhere it's just not
working and where are we at today drugs
are cheaper and more important than ever
if if you see prohibition as an attempt
to actually quash and reduce the use of
drugs then it's completely failed if you
see it as a mechanism of social social
control then it's highly effective so
it's really about the angle and I don't
like to say that War on Drugs has failed
because it has According to some metrics
but it really depends on the angle
through which you're framing it so
actually this publisher started in 1994
not 2004 because I want to appreciate
Rick Strassman who started doing DMT
research in 1994 in Santa Fe or
University of New Mexico before and I
would say a lot of people tend to credit
Dr Strassman for the beginning of what
we kind of see as the new Rave of
psychedelic research that's occurring
starting in 2004 though actually Maps
was able to start a clinical trials
there's a whole story that goes into
that but we started in Spain and have
kind of expanded over the course of last
bunch of years and as I said we just hit
a really beautiful Milestone of
finishing the phase three trials many
years later and now we have clinical
trials of LSD psilocybin Ayahuasca DMT
ibiguing ketamine and just like a bunch
of substances that also have a lot of
letters and numbers that some of which
are new some of which aren't and some of
that is really focused like I said
earlier on the treatment treatment of
mental health conditions you know we
write Mind Body illnesses because mental
health itself is a paradigm that is
useful to a certain extent and I think
that once you kind of come up to the
level of well how much of this is inside
my brain versus how much of this is a
social instructed experience it's harder
to kind of frame it as a mental health
thing it's like starting to be maybe
this is a result of our circumstances
environment who knows or maybe some
combination of those
so that is a decent overview and maybe
one thing I'll say before I get to where
we are now is this idea of uh lineages
and the way that some of this knowledge
has been maintained throughout history
as I said earlier there you know the
beginning of their oppression from the
Catholic Church the Spanish and
Portuguese governments and other
governments in the 1500s did not
necessarily it led to
eradication and genocide and all of this
oppression but it did not fully
eliminate the practice and I think I
really want to mention that there have
been continued unbroken lineages that
have occurred throughout history and
many of which have been interrupted and
then kind of reclaimed you could say and
I I think of myself as someone with
interrupted lineages my lineages were
interrupted by colonization and I really
worked toward reclaiming those things to
the extent that I can in modernity or
whatever which is a bit challenging
let's talk a little bit about where
we're at today so a number of local
policy changes have occurred in the last
few years I started working at maps in
2015 2016. I had been working on drug
policy for some time before that point
but when I started working I really
thought I was going to be in this little
niche of the drug policy world I was
like okay there's all this cool stuff
happening with safe injection and
medication she's just a treatment and
all these big cannabis legalization I'm
just going to be in my little corner
with psychedelics
and then two years passed and Michael
Paul had to change her mind and a bunch
of other things happened and suddenly it
went from being oh maybe we can one day
imagine what a psychedelic policy reform
Paradigm could look like to catching up
to a rapid increase of the types of
changes that we were maybe hoping to see
admittedly in kind of a world that
didn't really know what to do with that
speed of expansion in 2020 a lot of you
know this already Oregon voters approved
a measure two measures actually measures
110 and 109 to decriminalize the
personal use of most drugs that should
say most not all actually and develop
state legal access to psilocybin
treatments and regulated centers so I
was I on the equity subcommittee of that
program of the opab organ psilocybin
Advisory board up until just recently
and that program while being passed in
2020 had a two-year incubation period
you could say like a pre-implementation
and I imagine that people will start
getting treated under that framework in
about
um two months is like really where we're
at officially started the beginning of
this year but they have to train people
earlier just a few months ago similar
bill passes in Colorado I really love
the bill in Colorado proposition 122
because it both decriminalized the
personal use of a number of psychedelics
as well as created a regulated system
and as someone who's really committed to
decriminalization and moving away from
the criminalization of these substances
trying to find a balance where you can
have freedom to grow it yourself in your
home but also a regulated system if
that's what you want can be really
helpful and really informative in that
and of course since 2019 especially a
number of cities have considered drug
policy reform I have to put like kind of
policy nerd had on here real quick but
there's a lot of confusing media that
talks about decriminalization criminal
law tends to be enforced at the state
level state and federal level cities
don't enforce them they have law
enforcement but the actual enforcement
of the law happens at the state level
the reason that's relevant is because a
lot of cities that have been getting a
lot of news including Oakland including
San Francisco have de-prioritized
enforcement which basically means that
the city does isn't supposed to be
spending money on enforcing laws related
to that that's not quite the same thing
as decriminalization which is what we're
going for with SB 58 in California which
is reintroduced this year as well as
other bills including the win in
Colorado that are really like taking the
activity out of the criminal code at the
state level which removes that tool from
the prosecutor to do so the federal
government could still get involved if
they want but and that's Rabbit Hole
maybe we can go down the Q a if we want
but basically the federal government
tends right now seems to be relatively
wait and see about the things that are
happening which is very different from
what it was like with cannabis you know
20 years ago as I'm sure a lot of you
know
and this is an exciting one for those of
us that are kind of in the research
World there have been there's been a
total freeze um on federal funding for a
really long time the NIH National
Institute of Health and other Federal
entities are beginning to slowly slowly
put money toward research which is a
really big deal because up until this
point most of the research has been
funded by philanthropy and a little bit
increasingly by other kinds of
investment as although that's fairly
recent we're hoping that MDMA assistant
therapy will be considered by the FDA
that's a really big milestone that we're
really excited about at maps and also
it's a big deal for the field because it
would kind of be the beginning of what I
anticipate and what we anticipate will
be a wave of many substances with
multiple organizations that are all kind
of looking at what how could they be
incorporated into Healthcare is it
possible if so how and I do think that
there will be more substances and
indications that enter phase three
trials if not this year than very soon
and then lastly this is something I'm
really really excited about because as
we move towards decriminalization the
one thing I like to remind people is
that without education harm reduction
and crisis response we're kind of just
like throwing them bunch of new ideas
out there with very little support some
of you may have noticed we have a
rapidly deteriorating social safety net
so the
adoption of Public Health harm reduction
measures is like a major part of that
and I like to think of all of the
excitement around psychedelics of which
there is a lot nowadays as kind of a
trojan horse for other kinds of goods
sensible policies one being unarmed
crisis response for example you have
cities like Denver and Eugene Oregon
have programs that are calling in people
for Mental Health crisis that are not
armed that are trained in de-escalation
it's not perfect but I think that if we
funded de-escalation unarmed
de-escalation I think that we would
actually like the way especially if we
did the way that we funded cops law
enforcement I imagine that we might be
able to actually like have a different
type of intervention when things go
wrong on the street
as I hope so this this last piece is
about where we go from here first off
I'll say that I'm really excited about
the possibility of passing sb58 in
California we'll see for those that you
were following SB 519 was introduced by
Senator Scott weiner in
well December January 2021 and uh that
was there's a whole Saga and what
happened with that but it was
reintroduced this year after not passing
it's a little bit you know a little bit
simplified there's a few things that I
don't love about it like they took
ketamine out
why wouldn't you decriminalize no I mean
just just to go down a tiny rabbit hole
like if you're decriminalizing drugs for
a public health reason
the mushrooms are not the things that
are causing the overdoses people see
mushrooms and like oh this is a mushroom
it's actually imperative it's kind of
counterintuitive it's actually
imperative to decriminalize the white
powders because that's the stuff that
gets adulterated that's the stuff that
people actually have dangerous
experiences of it's kind of a sunlight
effect suddenly if the drug use has
decriminalized if assault happens or if
there's another crime another thing that
happens suddenly the people who are
using the drugs aren't afraid of being
implicated in crime suddenly they can
say oh this thing went wrong and I feel
safe bringing that up and actually
having some some sort of response to it
right now reporting a lot of negative
impacts is disincentivized because
people can't don't feel like they can
safely talk about something that
happened while drugs were involved so
yeah it's like funny but it's also very
serious it's completely serious that
like the overdose crisis that there's a
very very constant increasing and adult
increase in adulteration the quality of
drugs cheaper and better but also
scarier in many ways
so just to close I
I like to think a lot and one of the
things that inspired this conversation
is this idea of like what would a
wholesome drug culture look like as part
of the articulation of this lineage this
family history that I have that has
given me so much and allowed me to feel
so clear and with like kind of this Arc
that I feel like I'm participating along
with a lot of people here is the
possibility of not having drug use and
this process of healing and personal
growth and expansion to be something
that has to happen in the shadows
there's a lot of value in the shadow and
I encourage everybody to look closely at
yours but
but I do think that the fact that
psychedelics have been and Other Drugs
have been so stigmatized over such a
long time means that it's really hard to
have mature conversations about them and
it's very easy to like fall into the
realm of tropes and I get that all the
time in my work people are constantly
like in that kind of Trope stigma world
and it's actually quite radical to like
demystify some of that and make room for
these other ways of being that involve
family related work that involve
wholesomeness and wholeness I like to
think of it as doing drugs with dignity
can is it possible to have a
relationship with these substances that
actually allows me to be a dignified
person and maybe I'll close with a
little anecdote because I think it it
gets to what I'm what I'm hoping to see
in addition to custom LSD stores my
mother passed away 10 years ago and she
had cancer for 12 years it was actually
shortly after that that I left Fresno to
come up here to the Bay Area to start
Law School one of the things that
occurred in the wake of her passing was
uh like it has happened to many families
is like this rupture she was really like
the social major center of our kind of
collective social experience
we experienced a lot of grief as a
result of her passing
and in 2015 partially because of these
relational connections and this growth
my family started drinking Ayahuasca
together my grandmother and my aunts my
cousins my brothers three generations
we've not been doing that every few
years the experience of working with my
family in that context has really showed
me that this idea of psychedelics as
this wholesome vitamin nutrient as part
of our experience something that's been
part of our experience of Consciousness
and collectivism and Community for so
many years is that it's actually
possible to bring that back and to make
it something that's not just
I was gonna say not scary I don't think
it's possible to make succulents not
scary there's always gonna be a little
bit of that but certainly something that
doesn't have to be so stigmatized so
pushed out to the margins uh something
that's so difficult to actually have a
mature conversation about because one of
the things that I've noticed talking
about psychedelics with so many people
is that ultimately a lot of
conversations we have about psychedelics
are not about psychedelics they're about
grief they're about trauma they're about
expansion they're about Community
they're about connection they're about
all the things that psychedelics might
help reveal but the second Oak is really
just a tool just a catalyst and I like
to remind people that this idea of this
post-prohibition world that we're trying
to create has a lot more of all those
things hopefully more psychedelics too
but certainly also more kind of contact
with that essential aspect of ourself so
I just talked a lot I'll pause there for
now thank you so much for listening to
me appreciate it
thank you
so you've been going the medical route
but like
the American Medical system sort of like
notoriously flawed like often just
straight up horrifying
um you know like why why why go the
pharmaceutical route
um when there's so much like big
business big money and sort of like
scary entities that going on there yeah
it's a really good question I I'll share
first a little bit of like the way that
Rick Dublin the founder of maps frames
it which is uh this idea because keep in
mind that this organization was started
in uh 0901 986
um which means that a lot of those
opportunities like that we kind of see
now just didn't exist at that time and
you can kind of see the arc with
um cannabis where the beginning of
understanding it as a medical tool
before even prop 215 with in 96 here in
California you know I'm sure a lot of
you familiar with that history but even
before that you had this idea like oh
cannabis might be a medicine you know
for AIDS wasting syndrome or for cancer
these different indications and now like
even though there's a lot of flaws that
I can point out with the Cannabis
industry there is this level that like
oh normalizing it as a treatment maybe
is a way to get into
people's heads that oh maybe it's not as
scary as a lot of other as that's kind
of being treated
um so that's the one I would say
strategic justification
but your point is well taken and I agree
that the and especially now we can
really feel I'm sure folks that are
tracking like you can really see how
coming closer and closer to kind of the
formal Healthcare System is coming at
this really scary cost because suddenly
we have to deal with insurance suddenly
we have to deal with all of these kind
of regulatory Frameworks and all of
these economic realities that kind of
have created the monster that is
American Healthcare right now and I
tried to remember it's sometimes easier
than others but try to remind people
that in order to move toward really
Equitable access even through a purely
medical mental health frame we actually
like have a lot of other reform that
needs to happen whether it's with the
insurance system or the other pieces and
just one interesting anecdote is
we're working simultaneously in the US
and Europe and it's really interesting
to see how in Europe because a lot of
countries uh have their kind of internal
uh Healthcare Systems uh the kind of
logic or the um the calculus that's used
to determine whether or not a drug
should be approved is quite different
because there's this whole aspect that's
sort of taken off the table in certain
places in Europe where you actually
they're actually actually are thinking
about affordability in a way that you
don't really see American Healthcare
systems do it so I guess I guess the
dldr of that whole thing is there are a
lot of big costs and risks of engaging
with the US Healthcare System I feel
hyper aware of the way that that limits
accessibility and the way that I
probably personally balance that on like
the policy advocacy side is by making
sure that we have other points of access
whether it's sacramental use
decriminalized personal use and home
grow regulated adult use that side of
Medicine
I think that I'm a person that believes
in a lot of on-ramps and a lot of
off-ramps I think healthcare is one
really important place to go because a
lot of people will not go to underground
practitioners they need to go to a
psychiatrist they will not
and a lot of people I know that
um
you know don't want to go to an
underground practition like really want
to go to a psychiatrist or vice versa
who people who really will never go to a
psychiatrist will only go to underground
practitioners so I really see it as one
element in the toolkit
um with all the big caveats and risk
that you're describing yeah okay
thanks
um we've been talking about the medical
route but there is this whole religious
route you mentioned
um so you know our new conservative
Supreme Court has been using the
religious freedom exemption to like roll
back some civil liberties
um is there you know with this sort of
new framing of
um religious freedom that we're probably
going to see over the next few years
does that change anything in this space
this is a very interesting question
um because this is a very classic
strange bedfellows kind of situation
where the increased protections for
religious practice in the U.S that have
by the Supreme Court and others
overwhelmingly been used to benefit
reactionary
uh religious practice
have also been the same arguments that
have been used to permit
sacramental use of antigens
there's a major overlap in those two
arguments
so what that means is that
there's a I don't wanna
I don't want to call it a deal with the
devil but there's certainly this level
where
there's certainly this level where
um because of the increased
permissiveness that exists under the
religious freedom restoration Act and
the current kind of constitutional
religious freedom Productions as they
exist there's this kind of thing where
it's like oh every time more ground is
given there there's actually potentially
a stronger argument to permit
sacramental use of entheogenic or
practitioners who are working with
entheogens in Sacramento context to also
use those same benefits
I work very closely with with some
Churches
um some religious groups who work with
entheogens and it's definitely an area
that unlike medical use which has like a
really big regulatory framework that
we're already kind of plugging into
the religious freedom world is
it's a little bit harder to Define and
because it necess because the idea is
like oh get the government out of it it
means that there's a lot more need for
self-regulation Best Practices ethics
within those communities which is very
different kind of from a positionality
angle
um
and
I guess just to end the answer this I'll
say I wish that there were other
mechanisms for mechanisms for protection
of these practices but right now because
it requires making exemptions to
generally applicable laws which is what
we're seeing in these other places
because you get these churches you know
the more reactionary ones are getting
exemptions like civil rights laws like
generally applicable laws they're like
wait a minute that's not cool but then
suddenly we want an exception from the
Controlled Substances Act so our drug
use isn't considered drug use it's
considered a different thing
um and it's one of those places where
it's a legal argument framework and we
have to figure out like how how close to
the fire willing to get recognizing that
it's enhancing and engaging with these
systems these decisions as you described
what about the Dark Side of psychedelics
so you know there's
um historical reports of Viking
Berserkers eating the mushrooms before
their raids and go kill a bunch of
people but also in modern times you have
MK Ultra military applications and then
the most recent you know sort of like
right-wing acid head pandemic sort of
horror thing
um
uh you know well psychedelics free our
minds
I was at a conference in the fall and
um
I felt like such a wet blanket because
one of the questions that came up was
something like this they were like
when are the when are the elected reps
when are these old white guys going to
start doing psychedelics
why why aren't our representatives in
Congress doing psychedelics and the
interview at the like yeah yeah we got
to do that and then I had to be the
person to take them I can be like
everyone who you're scared of has been
doing psychedelics for a long time
I really can they fear our minds I
certainly feel like they've done a lot
for me personally
um even though I'm really careful not to
be an evangelist around that but
um not necessarily I'm a person that
believes that psychedelics tend to be
highly attuned to their environment I'm
not really sure if there's like an
inherent moral value in the molecules I
think that there's an argument for it
depending on the context and tradition
and so on but generally speaking I think
that psychedelics Canon R have been
throughout history utilized in a number
of different contexts not just the fun
ones that we were talking about but also
some
um more impressive and negative ones and
I do feel like that it's context
specific and I think that that's why I
feel so committed to figuring out how do
we design this post-prohibition
environment to make it possible for that
kind of
pro-social even that has a value frame
liberatory you could say used to be
possible
um and I think one of the risks of uh
kind of an unfettered
everything goes kind of framework is
that you allow people to abuse and
misuse that the power that comes with
access to psychedelics and the mind
states that um kind of are brought with
them to use them in a way that's that's
more harmful so I do I I try not to have
like
I try not to be too starry-eyed about it
because I do feel like that that context
really matters
um and I do have concerns that without
some groundwork cultural social
and so on
um that they they can and will be used
to harm people as they currently are in
some in some context so
well they fear in mind I hope so but I
don't think it's that simple and I think
we actually need to be quite diligent
about
yeah what it means for them to be coming
into the world stage in such a visible
way they've always been there but in
such a visible way in a way that they're
there now cool all right got a question
over here
I kind of want to follow this thread you
all just started I'm curious
how you think it'll really affect us in
the American culture I feel like we're
kind of in a suicidal moment here in the
United States all kinds of ways we're
killing ourselves and if it's a value
neutral molecule
and it's not the 60s and we're going for
a more integrated wholesome fruition
here how do you see that playing out
that's a good question
um I'm encouraged by some of the
research that's been coming out around
nature relatedness and openness I do
think that because the story of
psychedelics in the west has to do with
hippies in some ways I think that
actually kind of helps that cultural
context in the way that that association
means that many people who come into
contact with psychedelics overwhelmingly
who are not doing in illegal context
right are getting it with that cultural
context and that cultural history
so in some ways it's kind of like a
self-fulfilling thing where the story
and narrative around psychedelics is
things that open your mind like tend to
have the effects of opening people's
minds
um just like de facto in the wild
um of course that's not always true but
so that's kind of the optimistic
perspective
um I think to your point about like the
general suicidality of American culture
like that's a deep
question that I think
um to me intersects a lot with kind of
the hyper individualism of how we think
about mental health in the first place
and one of the concerns to kind of enter
your earlier point about incorporating
something into Healthcare without giving
all the rest of the context is that we
kind of treat psychedelics as the Silver
Bullet as just another thing to consume
which you do see in some even amazing
celebratory party cultures you still see
that
and
um I do worry that psychedelics are not
as strong as in that sense in the
culture in in not as not strong enough
to really break out of that and I don't
know
um I was at a conference some years ago
and
um someone asked a question about
psychedelics and capitalism what happens
when they intersect
and um someone brought up the anecdote
that uh in the 80s as you had the rise
of televangelism
a lot of people thought that
Christianity was stronger than
capitalism and they were like it'll
never get subsumed into that so I don't
I try not to be like too hyper
optimistic about the fact that
psychedelics whether or not they're
neutral or however they fit like can and
will be incorporated into the monster of
consumption that defines so many of our
lives and that is a concern that I have
which is also why I fight for homegirl
because if you care if you can home grow
then a lot of that changes but again
it's a longer conversation but that
shadow is very real
got one over there I was wondering if
you could tell us a little bit more
about the state law the California state
law and particularly
and got taken out of it I find that
interesting because
Kaiser will give it to me
and I get ads for it on Facebook all the
time
um let's talk about ketamine
um so we were talking about this before
because people were like wait a minute
how am I getting Facebook ads like how
what in what pair day
um
I'll talk about the bill first answer
question then maybe I'll get on subox
after that
um so uh shortly after Oregon voters
passed uh measures 109 110 in November
2020.
um Senator Scott weiner tweeted actually
uh I want to pass the Bill about
psychedelics and it was funny because no
one it was kind of you know we're all
like oh my God there's going to be a
bill in California about psychedelics
let's do this and there was a coalition
that was brought together in early 2021
the original language of the bill uh
decriminalized the personal use of six
substances
psilocybin DMT ibogaine mescaline
excluding masculine from parody uh
ketamine MDMA and LSD so seven
um and there are a number of changes
that were made over the course of its
kind of traversing through the various
committees within the legislature in the
assembly and one of those changes was
eventually all of the synthetics were
taken out so the version that was
reintroduced this year just has DMT
psilocybin mescaline not from peyote and
ibogaine
so over the course of a couple years all
the synthetics were eventually taken out
but ketamine was the first so ketamine
has a reputation although
I think that it's over indexed in law
enforcement world as a date rape drug
and along with GHP and rufinol and
that's based on DEA data that I did a
lot of digging on and couldn't find the
source for but
not to say it doesn't happen I'm not
trying to diminish that I'm just like
there were a lot of claims that were
being made early on about ketamine
specifically and the argument and an
argument was made like whoa it's
available legally so why can't we just
decriminalize it
um and the reasoning ultimately I think
boiled down to this idea that like white
powders are really scary and synthetics
are not something we can just create we
can just allow it to be out there and
even with my like super
anti-prohibitionist frame there's some
logic to that in the sense that people
are not that afraid of growing cacti or
mushrooms in their backyard or in their
closet but like once you start to talk
about synthetics if you don't have like
a safe Supply like an actual Supply
mechanism then suddenly you have labs in
residential areas some of you may have
seen there was an explosion in San
Francisco last week that was a BHO lab
in underground
cannabis extraction lab that was in that
home
so people are really afraid of that and
it was interesting because one of the
issues that came up when I testified in
the California state legislature around
this bill was the question came up like
where did the drugs come from and we're
arguing the whole time we're like let us
pass safe Supply let us have a regulated
like Supply mechanism but that was past
the line that what people were willing
to do so we could only decriminalize
personal use
um but that is the Paradox which is like
why can't we
get access to the things it's because of
this kind of supply and manufacture
question so that's the reasoning it was
taken out but just to say a little bit
more about why I think it's a big
problem that it was taken out is that
first off one thing that I think a lot
of legislators and maybe law enforcement
aren't thinking of that's so intuitive
is that when you I believe that when we
if we were to decriminalize certain
substances you would actually reduce the
adulteration of those substances because
you would disincentivize cutting those
substances with a drug especially if the
other drug is still illegal so if you
decriminalize MDMA Suddenly It's really
unlikely that you'd get MDMA analogs on
the street because why would you sell a
drug that's still sort of illegal if you
could just sell the real thing
um of course that's like kind of basic
logic it doesn't always work that way in
the underground it's not quite so simple
but that was kind of like the the
reasoning and the direction
and ultimately uh the move toward
keeping it to just plant-based
substances was seen as being kind of
more viable as we see I saw in Colorado
so I think that will continue to be the
first wave is like where it's like
really plant oriented
um but I would like to see from a period
Public Health perspective white powders
also get decriminalized because those
are the ones that the most dangerous
how can this policy go forward when
public
drug useism
how's that going to be fixed a lot of
polling is happening to start a lot of
polling is happening especially in the
states where you're seeing legislative
legislation move forward and this year I
think that there will be a dozen bills
introduced there may already be a dozen
bills introduced across the country
um so what's happening is you have
there's like the True Believers that
have been in it for a long time and now
literally in the last two years it went
from being like am I going to be a
legislator that sticks my neck out for
this issue to being like oh I can't be
the last one on this issue that happened
really fast
so I would slightly push back that is
the public opinion of public opinion
but it's not actually so true anymore
um partially because of the kind of the
again the desperation the need and of
course the narrative that I didn't go
into that I went too much today around
like veterans and PTSD and survivors of
sexual assault and like we need to help
people how do we help people so there's
actually this kind of which to me is a
little bit scary that's kind of a
pendulum swinging to like too much hype
um but you'd be surprised at how open
people are now because they're getting
so much they're hearing so much about
all of this hype and I feel like part of
our job at Maps is to like keep it like
yeah we're really excited too but
actually there's risks and we should
talk about those risks and we should
mitigate them by having crisis response
and education
um so yeah that's changed fast I'm not
saying that there's a lot of people who
still feel that way
um but I would say rapidly decreasing
now people are getting way too excited
do drugs come off schedule one
historically
um I love this question
um so
little drug policy nerd moment
um there's this concept called a
bifurcated scheduling
one of those legal fictions so right now
um drugs are on these different
schedules right control substance tax
Schedule one through five one being the
most restrictive by being the least
um do drugs come off of the schedule so
cannabis currently has three derivative
drugs that are all of that are legally
available
Marinol and epidiolex all of those are
cannabis derived cannabis
good old weed is still schedule one but
you're like wait a minute schedule one
requires that there's no medical use if
you have proven medical use how can it
stay in schedule one the government has
invented this concept called bifurcated
scheduling where the drug product which
is the term of our which refers to the
drug that's approved by the FDA which
includes the manufacturing framework the
Rems the risk evaluation of Education
strategy all the things that come with
the thing it goes down I mean it says
detail is like the color of the pills
what's on the package that is a drug
product
the drug product even if the molecule is
identical is scheduled separately
so you've got three drugs that are
cannabis derived at a non-schedule one
while cannabis is still in schedule one
and our current theory is that with with
MDMA and with psilocybin that really
working against this don't I'm not
endorsing this but it's very possible
that the uncontrolled version of those
drugs remains in schedule one while the
drug product gets placed in the schedule
other than schedule one
and the important the thing that's
important about that that's also
relevant is that scheduling and
criminalization are not always linked
criminalization is a multi-tiered thing
that's also highly influenced by the U.S
sentencing commission which is the
judicial Federal Judicial body that
basically sets norms for um sentencing
in the United States
um trickles down to the state level
so I like to remind people I appreciate
that kind of question like I like to
remind people that moving away from even
if we were to fully deschedule or
reschedule that alone would not
necessarily eliminate criminalization
that may take more advocacy at the
sentencing level at the state level
decriminate and so on that so it'd be
nice that would make sense like oh it's
like them higher up than the worse or
whatever but it's not
quite so simple but we are working
toward that and there is a big push to
actually fully deer reschedule it's I
think it's possible for example that
cannabis gets fully descheduled to taken
out of the control substance sector
that's pretty optimistic but it's not
it's not crazy whereas I think the other
drugs it'll be harder to take them off
but it may be possible if we have a more
sane policy to actually just kick them
out of schedule one at least
okay I think that sort of leads well
into the last question how do we you
know
how do we make sure this legalization
and decriminalization process is
accessible you know it doesn't just
benefit people who have access to
resources or who can navigate the
insurance system in the right way but
actually has effects on the prison
system and you know doesn't end up you
know ends up being sort of a fair
distribution
so unlike the prohibition of heroin or
cocaine or Methamphetamine or even
cannabis where you have
a large identifiable population that's
been impacted by those criminalizations
you've got a lot of people in prison
because of those drugs basically
um
so you can really see the impact of the
current drug control scheme with respect
to people who use those drugs
psychedelics it's a little bit harder
because as I mentioned a lot of the
criminalization and the kind of cultural
context that
um allowed psychedelics to be
criminalized and repressed so early
meant that a lot of the the work that
had to get done by prohibition you could
say it was already it was already
happened my ancestors a lot of our you
know the my cultural history like the
use of psychedelics had been already had
been repressed for 400 years by the time
Nixon came along you know
so I say that to say that
um
one thing that we can do that we have
been pushing at the state level is
pairing any decriminalization with
expungement and with kind of the
elimination of Records but even if we
were to do that just looking at this
soberly the number of people who had
benefited by wiping records related to
psychedelics is still quite small not to
say that it's not important MDMA right
now is the of the psychedelics we can
argue whether or not MDMA but
um of the kind of Classics I get those
MDMA is the one that's been the most
heavily enforced and those numbers are
in like the single digits or lower most
of the and they may be over you know we
may have may know more people who've
been impacted by that because of the
world that we may or when I be in but
overall the numbers fairly small so what
I like to say is I think that in
addition to decriminalization like real
decrim where you can have homegirl where
there's actually no mitigator between
you and the substance where you can just
grow it yourself I think that the other
thing that I like to do in my call to
action sometimes in conversations like
this is that for people that are
interested in psychedelic
decriminalization or psychedelic policy
to actually bring that energy to these
other
um these other drugs and these issue
related to Other Drugs supervised
consumption sites medication assisted
treatment actual housing and care for
people who are addicted or dependent on
other drugs like that type of thing
people can say forever like once a drug
user always a drug User it's always the
same it's kind of like the point that
was being made earlier like well isn't
it just morally bad
I think that until all people who choose
to use drugs are able to be treated with
dignity we're just making gains on
something that could always be pulled
out from under our feet so I do think
that moving toward that really broad
vision for post prohibition World
um that actually has access to health
care and support and housing and
environmental justice and all the other
things that we really want to see I
think that like I like to say like pivot
that energy that's about that's focused
on psychedelics and that comes out of
that personal growth into these other
places where we can bring Justice
because to me if we don't you know if
we're not all free and working together
to eradicate the stigma then like it can
always be turned against us in the long
run so I see that as like we're all part
of this together like you can think of
yourself as different from someone who's
using Fenton on the street but the
government doesn't so we got to work for
all of us if we're trying to do anything
at all
all right
thank you so much
thank you
[Music]